did Apple just kill the airpods max with
their release of the new Beats Studio
Pro well based off the specs the airpods
max just got destroyed but what I'm
curious about are the things that specs
don't show like sound quality active
noise cancellation comfort and more so
we're going to be testing all of that I
want to say I do like the packaging that
these come in at and look at that right
out of the box this is what a case
should look like we should have not got
this embarrassing thing that I never
ever use this thing feels nice we have a
little carry handle right there let's
open it up okay that is interesting so
it doesn't open up all the way let's
pull these out all right well I will
stay right out of the get-go the quality
does not feel as nice as the stainless
steel and aluminum design of the airpod
pods Max now Weight Wise yeah you
definitely can tell the difference we
have some Pockets here for the USB
type-c cable and look at this a three
and a half millimeter jack cable which
you have to pay extra for from Apple for
the airpods max that is a lightning to
three and a half millimeter now that is
one of the things that really bugs me
about the airpods max when the battery
dies on this well you can't use it while
charging and you can't use the three and
a half mil to lightning cable either you
have to charge them first whereas with
the Beats no problem plug it in use it
even if the battery is dead and with
that said the battery difference is
massive basically double the battery
life and I don't buy what Apple says
about the battery life still being good
without the case because they go into
low power mode it still drains a lot and
often when I want to use them they are
dead which definitely sucks whereas with
the beats you can fold them and as soon
as you do it shuts them off and then as
soon as you open them back up bam they
are powered on I love that and of course
the compactness factor having those be
able to fold it's much nicer to put into
your bag but what about Comfort let's go
ahead and get a refresher with these I
love how comfortable they are you do
have a little bit of extra pressure on
the sides but the top is super soft
after a while you do feel the weight but
they are still extremely comfortable now
with these you have a standard band a
lot less expensive to make a little bit
harder to open them up but let's try
this out well right out of the get-go I
would say these are not as comfortable I
have a little bit less pressure here but
I definitely feel that band much more so
now the ear cups themselves also don't
feel as soft they are memory kind of
foam here but compared to these ears
cups those are softer and of course
these swap out mine are starting to wear
out they're magnetic super super cool
feature whereas you will not get that
with the Beats now I could see or feel
why these are 350 dollars compared to
550. our touchpad is all plastic and
it's just a standard clicking kind of
pad feels really cheap compared to that
digital crown that we have built in and
this button which is so nice to be able
to just scroll up and down click tap
here to switch between your different
modes this is much nicer with the
airpods max pairing them should be just
as easy as air pods but for some reason
I just have a white box over here and
just like with our airpods Max right
there in the settings they show up you
have all your options built in without
needing an app there's even personalized
spatialized audio built in find my
support that is really cool and now
let's come compare the noise
cancellation let's start out with just
how much sound it blocks I have it set
to off Vadim go ahead and say something
hey what's up man how's it going good
it's going good you sound a little bit
muffled but I can hear you and what
about the airpods max all right say
something now hey what's up man how's it
going you are definitely quieter with
the airpods max I hear less of my voice
I hear a lot less of that HVAC sound wow
so this definitely has more sound
blocking I'm probably talking quieter
too now let's turn on noise cancellation
here
wow all the sound went away even my
voice is low and it went away but even
say something hey what's up man how do I
sound even quieter it's this works
really well actually I think the latest
softer update improved it and with the
Beats here
wow okay
that got a lot quieter compared to
without it but even go ahead and say
something uh how do you hear me good
you're louder you're louder than with
the airpods max definitely and most of
that 8-track noise went away I hear a
tiny bit of the high end but let's take
this up a notch as you guys can hear we
got the airplane noise turned up on Max
in the off setting
definitely blocks it out let's set your
noise cancellation on
okay
it's a little louder than I thought it
would be cut out a lot of the low end
but the high end is still coming through
let's put on the airpods max here
[Music]
oh yeah definitely quieter now it's not
a crazy difference but it's definitely
noticeable especially on the high end so
if you care about the best noise
cancellation airpod Max definitely take
the win but what about transparency mode
I know the laptops live down there
all right oh this sounds like I don't
have anything on so amazing with airpods
we didn't talk for a sec do I sound good
you sound identical to what you actually
yeah it's transparency modes on that is
insane all right beats please don't let
me down I love the folding feature I
want to replace my earpods with this
okay
ah no not good
not as good though you sound pretty good
my voice sounds off for some reason the
left one doesn't sound as good maybe if
I turn my head
and the HVAC noise sounds fake
it's just nowhere near the quality it's
usable better than a lot of third-party
other companies but man I wonder if they
did this on purpose to make sure they
don't destroy these man that is
disappointing now what about the
microphone quality this is the
microphone quality using the new Beats
Studio Pro and this is the microphone
quality using Apple's airpods Max which
are around two and a half years old now
and now back to the Beats Studio Pro let
me know what you think in terms of
Micron quality which one sounds better
down in the comments below and now let's
compare the sound quality we're gonna
have a few different tracks here you
guys can hear what I am listening to
let's get started
[Music]
where we started
okay not a bad start I feel like the
airpods max are a little bit louder but
these do not disappoint in volume a lot
of other headphones just aren't loud
enough at least for me and the bass
sounded great I can't give one a win
over the other video what about uh noise
leakage sound leakage leaked more
okay probably because of the kind of ear
cup design compared to this one and the
airpods feel like they're a lot more
sealed in wow okay let's go to the next
track
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow okay well that sucks if they don't
shut off automatically there's no sensor
in here so that's a cost savings and I
think it's nice to just take it off
somebody could walks up to you if you
don't want to put it to transparency
mode or pause uh but the sound quality
sounds very good
very balanced I think the high is a
little bit brighter the bass sounds
really deep and they are so close in
terms of sound quality wow okay well now
let's put the toughest track which is a
rock track that has a lot of instruments
a lot of layers and let's see how they
compare again they didn't pause
automatically they know when you put it
on one thing I noticed is that as soon
as I put them on they switch so fast to
these they pair so quick probably newer
Tech maybe this has Bluetooth 5.3
compared to 5.0 but the sound quality
wise airpods Max won it out in here uh
here the highs are a little too sharp
there's less separation between the
different layers of instruments still
sounds great the bass sounds great I
don't think anybody to complain about
how this sounds Apple did a good job
tuning them but in the toughest tracks
the airpod max does go ahead but for
everything else they sound so close so
you will not be disappointed in terms of
sound now there's one more thing that's
very special special about these
headphones the airpods max do not have
and that is the ability to play lossless
audio even if you connect these with the
lightning to three and a half mil Jack
they still do a bunch of processing
internally and you don't get the full
codec it's still down sampled whereas I
have this plugged in with USB type-c and
as you guys see they connected to my Mac
and even though I don't have them paired
with Bluetooth it shows up as USB audio
output which is super cool and now I can
open up Apple music switch to high-res
lossless audio and listen at full best
quality now I don't think I could play
the song for you guys because of
copyright let's take a listen alright
guys so I just listened to them both
ways I switched back and forth
and I didn't think I would be able to
tell the difference because this song
already sounds amazing but I did notice
the difference in the high frequencies
uh just sounds like you have a little
bit more detail a little bit more there
a little less flat I don't know what the
best ways to describe it now it was
interesting that when I'm playing
lossless plugged in as soon as I hit
play the active noise cancellation shuts
off and it's giving you the pure sound
without any processing exactly how it is
at Full Resolution instead of keeping
and doing other processing that could
happen when you're going over Bluetooth
now of course it depends on the track
you're using some will you'll notice a
bigger difference but that is so awesome
to be able to do this and at the same
time it's charging compared to not being
able to on headphones that are way more
expensive so that is a major win for the
Beats Studio Pros now I wanted to test
one more thing just to test out the qual
quality of the base that is how low
these can get because the airpods do an
amazing job and I cycled through 30
Hertz so loud 20 Hertz still loud in
fact the Beats actually play 20 Hertz a
little bit louder than the airpods Max
and they're known for getting really
really deep low bass so the quality of
the bass is awesome it's not that just
you have a lot of bass but these hit
deep and that is very impressive for me
so with all of that tested do the new
Beats Studio Pros
kill the airpods max well if you don't
mind a little more headband pressure a
little bit worse active noise
cancellation and the transparency mode
with these and especially if you want
the form factor the price tag the
lighter weight and less clamping
pressure I would say yes now airpods Max
are definitely better in some ways but
for 200 less having double the battery
life having sound quality that is just
as good possibly better depending on
what you're listening to if you're using
the loss list and all the extra
capabilities a lot less limitations I
think these are a major win from me you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below we'll have a
link to these as well as the link to
discounted airpods Max go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those great videos
right over there and I will see you in
the next one
[Music]
thank you